Bill Clinton got his dick sucked in the
White House so how [ __ ] bad could you
like possibly be
[Music]
yo what up its game chillin in
Manchester man it's the man Bible yeah
and I'm running the show today so we got
some questions from a bunch of people
man you know what we're gonna do we
gotta answer them for you
so first up Harry swiller that sounds
like a dude it just [ __ ] mad [ __ ]
all day he wants to know my girlfriend
told me she wants gave somebody a
[ __ ] and a pub should I get my [ __ ]
and leave damn yeah yeah and leave
eventually it's pretty [ __ ] up man
Mirko Mirko
that's a dumb [ __ ] name by the way
alright Mirko has will there ever be a
boy boy who can swim faster than a
shuffle man there's no child man human
being that's ever gonna be born it's
able to swim faster than a shark unless
he has a [ __ ] rocket pack on his back
so I mean as much as I mean it's a
creative question but it's almost
outright stupid maybe in the car tellers
next up we got Jen go yeah I like that
name django django wants to know did you
ever get your bike back that was stolen
and haters love it thanks well number
one Django I never said I got my [ __ ]
bike stolen
love it that was $0.50 so you should go
back and listen to the [ __ ] song
again because I wasn't my [ __ ] bike
and again if he stole my bike I whupped
Joe ass and sorry for the sweat so just
you know is this gangster rapper
vocabulary you know so if I offended
anybody out there [ __ ] you Alexander the
Great
I thought he died well it's a little
it's crazy all right Alexander the Great
the new one Alexander the Great Junior
or something I think my ex is pregnant
with my child what do I do your proper
[ __ ]
the lad Bible where else would you go
it's the only bottle giving these lads a
bunch of banter